you've probably heard that the
top speed of some type of aircraft is
mock
is mach 2
or maybe you watch some type of i don't
know science fiction movie or some type
of fighter movie where they say hey we
are going to travel
at
mach
at mach 1.8
and you had a sense because they're
using it in the same context that you
would use a speed that this is some type
of speed
that these numbers represent some type
of speed and if you assume that you are
right and the speeds they represent are
actually a multiple or depending on how
you want to view it multiple or
fractions of the speed of sound in that
medium so if you want if someone tells
you that the mach number is two
what that tells you is that they are
traveling
they are traveling
two times
the speed
speed of sound
in
that
medium for those conditions and i make
those last two
i guess qualifiers on it because the
speed of sound is not always the same it
has a different speed depending on
whether it's traveling in air or water
or even depending on what makes up the
air
and even if it is only traveling in a
certain type of air with a certain you
know with a certain makeup of mix of
gases it'll also change depending on the
temperature so if you're if you're at if
you're at sea level at roughly about 20
degrees celsius the speed of sound is
300 so
sea level do a different color maybe
blue for sea level so if you're at sea
level
if you are at sea level the speed of
sound is about 340
meters per second this is a 20 degrees
celsius so it's a nice comfortable
temperature
at at sea level which is roughly about
760 miles per hour now if the
temperature were to drop so if
temperature goes down
if the temperature
goes down so does the speed of sound
sound
speed
also goes down and likewise if the
temperature goes up the speed of sound
goes up so when someone tells you that
something is traveling at mach 2 they're
saying it's traveling at two times the
speed of sound for that medium usually
they're talking about something
traveling through air and for the speed
of sound at the temperature that they're
going through so if they're traveling
you know if they're at some super high
altitude and normally to travel at these
types of speeds you have to be at a
fairly high altitude where the air is
less dense
you're also traveling in an environment
where the temperature is significantly
lower than
six you know than 20 degrees celsius so
the speed of sound so you might say hey
does that mean if someone's traveling at
mach 2 does that mean that they're
definitely traveling at 680 meters per
second or at 1520
miles per hour and of course whenever
someone gives you an airspeed it's
relative to the air the answer is no
they're probably going to be traveling a
little bit slower than that because at
the altitude that they're traveling the
speed of sound is slower now there are
peop you know there are ground speed
records where they are traveling in kind
of the mock range where their velocities
are high enough to stay in terms of mach
and for those uh types of situations
they are traveling at multiples of 760
miles per hour 340 meters per second now
you're probably saying hey who is this
this this person right here that that
i've i've cut and paste from wikipedia
this is ernst mock and this is what the
mach number this is who the mach number
is named after
ernst
mock and he was this austrian physicist
and philosopher
and he did a ton of research on shock
waves and sound waves and whatnot so the
mach number is named after him